un
sentiment de déjà-vu pour beaucoup
un président américain venus déposer des
fleurs sur un même montréal de victimes
abattu par un tireur
la visite de joe biden était très
attendue dans cette communauté encore
gravement marquée par la tuerie de
samedi
la suprématie blanche est un poison lent
sur bayonne
[Applaudissements]
nous devons refuser de vivre dans un
pays dit il où les personnes noires qui
font leurs courses peuvent se faire tuer
avec des armes de guerre
une arme de guerre que le tireur aurait
obtenu légalement les jeunes
ouailles il aurait dû être surveillés
dit elle et ne l'était pas
et ce n'est pas juste bas fullum et
toute la communauté noire aux etats-unis
qui est ébranlé par ce massacre motivé
par la haine raciale de la nation
il faut que ceux-ci simule une
conversation nationale dit kelly rocco
faire tout ce qui est humainement
possible pour éradiquer ce mal qui est
la suprématie blanche
des bleus freeman a vu le physique sur
internet
lorsqu'il s'est retrouvé devant jeune
homme blanc allongé qui se protéger dit
elle il s'est excusé et a continué de
tirer sur des personnes noires c'est un
cauchemar
cela va encore se reproduire dit elle
car le racisme est profondément ancré
dans le système
les gens continuent à déposer des fleurs
les prêtres viennent parler d'amour et
de pardon
on va faire ce qu'on fait d'habitude dit
elle être au dessus
on parle de résilience avec un sentiment
de plus en plus amer il s'est sabordé
guerguisse radio-canada bachelot